and finally new rule from now until
Election Day everything else every issue
every fight every cause has to take a
backseat to defeating Trump he's like an
infection you don't fool around with it
look we all have our issues that are
important to us and so just to lead by
example let me say that I will take my
own close to the heart pet cause pot
legalization off the table and you know
me I have seeds in my urine but if you
know that but if something if someone
told me that pushing for pot might cost
Hillary Ohio until November 8th I'm just
gonna shut the [ __ ] up about it now I
know liberals are feeling pretty good
about Hillary's chances this week but
history has taught us the Democrats are
pretty good at blowing elections and
Republicans are masters at winning
elections with solutions in search of a
problem and the problem they're
imagining lately is that the
transgendered or sex fiends pretending
to be transgendered roam America's
restrooms in drag
looking for a chance to watch people pee
okay here's what we can't do this
election get tricked into symbolic
fights about college campus pet peeves
Hillary if someone asks you if Christmas
is unfair to the desert to the disabled
because the reindeer laugh at Rudolph's
nose just say I don't care I know we're
liberals and there's an infinite list of
ideas for making the world better by
making it less like duck dynasty
but there's no room for boutique issues
in an Armageddon election and look I'm
I'm on the side of people peeing where
they want it's an in Elia Beloit I
believe it was Patrick Henry who once
said nobody beats The Wiz and I'm not
suggesting that we throw the
transgendered under the bus or discount
their struggle it can't be easy finding
pantyhose when you're six four but this
is exactly the kind of culture war issue
that R ousts a certain type of voter out
of their trailers on Election Day as we
speak Ann Coulter is finishing a new
book called urination how liberals are
giving it to America in the can let's
not die on this hill because I've seen
this movie before in the 2000 election
Al Gore distance himself from a very
successful Clinton administration
because the Republicans made it seem
like every time Monica Blue Clinton he
was holding her hair
and then there was 2004 when George W
Bush got caught invading the wrong
country so they changed the issue to gay
marriage because this was before a gay
marriage was popular even in 2008 Obama
was still saying this I believe that
marriage is the union between a man and
a woman now did he say that because he
meant it no he just wanted the
distraction off the table to make sure a
method didn't wind up folks to most
people elections are about jobs and
college and terrorism not social issues
and the people who lead on social issues
aren't in Washington anyway they're here
in Hollywood this transgender thing let
us handle it like we did with gay rights
which very few cared about until
Hollywood put gay people in every single
TV show until America not only came to
accept gays they began to wonder if
anyone in high school wasn't gay
we hit him with glee and Ellen and Will
and Grace and Queer Eye for the straight
guy and pretty soon being gay was just
part of our modern family we have
we have a long history of mainstreaming
non-traditional families punky brewster
lived with an old man for some reason
and we didn't ask and we didn't tell
saying with Major Nelson who kept his
girlfriend in a jar this is what we're
good at and we've already begun to do it
for the transgendered with the Danish
girl and Dallas buyers club and
transparent and of course there's
Caitlyn Jenner who has already showed
Americans that a transgendered person
could be just like them a deluded nitwit
who supports Donald Trump